use that whole area there for dropping
pallets Chris weeks has been battling
the chaos for days he and his team from
German logistics company DHL are one of
the most experienced disaster management
outfits worldwide and are currently
based at Kathmandu Airport the challenge
facing them today is to distribute the
unending stream of relief supplies as
they come in once you unload one plane
and you drop all the cargo on the ground
you can't use that space again until
it's been moved so then another plane
comes in and you've dumped that cargo on
the ground then you can't use that space
either and then it gets worse as you
can't get to move around to get any of
the cargo out and that's roughly what is
starting to happen here
the Nepalese military is doing
everything it can the blue bags contain
tents which must be urgently dispatched
to 2.8 million people rendered homeless
by the earthquake but the soldiers can
only cope with smaller loads the bigger
aid deliveries require man and machine
over the last 5 years many years before
that none of the freight was coming in
loose loaded and in on small pallets now
it's coming on these big aircraft
pallets that need you can't move them
with your muscles you have to have
equipment which is one of the problems
in a country like Nepal the equipment is
pretty scarce you've got an old forklift
here that's probably 25 years old and
it's lacking power and friction but we
have to use what we what we've got
weeks might be director of humanitarian
affairs at DHL but he has a technical
background and doesn't shy from getting
his hands dirty to ensure progress after
a few manual adjustments the forklift
truck is able to hoist the huge load of
food supplies but as soon as one
challenge is met there comes another a
colleague nearby has just realised that
they're almost out of fuel vital for the
tractors bringing the empty pallets back
to reload further supplies disasters
happening in the region where there's no
big international airport so it's a
challenge every time we deployed we face
the same challenges space equipment and
resources but certainly we've been here
now for 48 hours and things are
beginning to get a lot more organized
the main road past the airport also
shows increasing signs of returning to
normal but here too the 7.8 magnitude
earthquake has left its devastating mark
despite the gaping cracks an asphalt
road like this is still usable
many of the unpaved roads and tracks in
more remote areas however are completely
destroyed and that's a headache at the
distribution center that's been set up
next to the airport there's no shortage
of food supplies here or a desperately
needed drinking water the big problem
remains getting the supplies to their
destinations we have employed one
helicopter now to start distribution in
Gorka district which started yesterday
burqa and adding district and if
everything goes well and we managed to
transport food we will start
distribution from tonight or tomorrow in
WA code and in the cultural district but
it just it's just transporting how Road
Transport has been very difficult a few
days later Chris weeks from the DHL
logistics team is in far better spirits
than at the start of their mission time
for the morning briefing
so maybe Kim and Kim can go on the on
the lookout for that some nice shiny
yellow stuff I hope so you like boys in
a toy shop at Christmas same with all
these new toys the desperately needed
equipment arrives just in time a batch
of new forklift trucks should enable the
team to pick up the pace of their
deliveries
and there's more good news tiltrotor
aircraft from the american military have
likewise arrived having vertical landing
capability means they can reach
otherwise inaccessible mountain areas
you